hallo mein name ist luca und ich habe
bereits vor einigen tagen den ersten
teil dieses spiels hochgeladen wir sind
auf der seite
[Musik]
ja es gibt auch einen teil 2 und den
spielen wir heute hier haben wir wieder
die auswahl zwischen nord und lässt den
slot in der letzten folge haben wir
gelernt dass wir lieber den normen mode
nehmen hier haben wir nämlich zehn leben
können hier springen und hier
uns neuerdings auch trocken lassen also
neuerdings können uns auch hier
irgendwie brücken und wir können halt
springen das heißt wir spielen auf den
ersten drauf der geht noch der zweite
geht auch noch denn
es war klar aber wir lernen natürlich
aus unseren fehlern wir springen hier
und springen über den drücken
genau könne auf den ersten rauf auf den
zweiten drauf und nun hier hin und hier
das ding hat sich gerade bewegt es gibt
also viele neue sachen in diesem level
in diesem zweiten teil sage ich
es gibt einige neue sachen die sich
verändert haben
das heißt wir müssen ganz ganz war mein
gott
ja wahrscheinlich oder also viele sachen
haben sich hier verändert es sind viele
neue sachen hinzugekommen dass h
wie habe ich das vorhin gemacht hier
darauf auf den ersten dann hier dann
die
habe ich das vorher hingekriegt
jetzt frage ich schon hier also jetzt
ist der stein da wenn ich allerdings hin
springe ist so total bescheuert also ich
muss warten dann muss es da
ich weiß auch nicht was dieser knopf
hier bin
das ist ein pause knopf wie habe ich das
denn wohin gemacht
bin ich denn da drauf gesprungen das
kann doch nicht sein ich weiß wie ich
will noch mal eine wiederholung wie ich
das für ihn gemacht habe
[Musik]
jetzt hat luca im schnitt euch eine
wiederholung eingeblendet und was bringt
es mir ich kann es mir jetzt nicht noch
mal angucken
und jetzt so also ich weiß jetzt wie das
ganze funktioniert ich muss warten bis
er da ist darunter springen
genauso also ich weiß jetzt wie das
ganze funktioniert ich muss laufen
runterspringen hier
das vielfach ich leicht aggressiv also
einfach laufen springen sollte bin ich
hier jetzt hier warten so rüber springen
und jetzt bin ich in den nächsten level
das level 4 o mein gott nein ich muss
schnell sein und was das denn für eine
scheiße ich komme da nicht rein hab ich
etwas mache ich jetzt springe was ist
das wird level wie soll ich denn daher
sind die denn bescheuert wie soll ich
denn da rein springen hätte ich da
irgendwie hin krabbeln hinten hin gehen
hin irgendwie sowieso dieser solche
machen moment
was soll ich in diesem level zu ich weiß
nicht ob ich darüber springen
das funktioniert nicht da rein springen
geht auch nicht darüber auch nicht
irgendwie hier dunkel zu anderen seite
kann ich auch nicht irgendwie gehen
ich finds halt auch mega entspannt dass
man dann einfach wieder von vorne
anfangen muss also ist ja überhaupt
nicht stressig oder so ist ja alles
komplett okay so ich bin hier drauf war
in ordnung also ich glaube ich warte bis
die kugel da reingeht so aha ok und
jetzt kann ich auch vor lauter das ist
nicht wahr
jetzt
nicht
was mache ich denn jetzt wo ich denn
jetzt hin der kombi kugel wieder von
einer anderen seite also auf die kugel
warten bis sie davor läuft genauso jetzt
darunter jan peter meding daher muss
aber okay wir warten ab und sonne da
hätte ich auch wieder drunter her
gemusst so wir warten mal wieder und
sagt ja auch wieder drunter her musste
karten mal so sagt da ist sich weg so
als ob ich hier hin jetzt kommt da die
seite raus jetzt ob ich hier wieder hin
jetzt bewegt sich wieder die hunde von
der st
kugel 1
wow
so warten in laufen
das ding kommt ich will die kugel oh
mein gott heilige scheiße
hatten
kugel in lauffen das ding kommt
offen kugel holen die kugel holen google
holen jetzt hier
wow
das ist super spiel also hier hinlaufen
drucken die kugel kommt jetzt hoffe ich
wieder hierhin jetzt kommt da das
komische ding jetzt will ich hier hinten
die kugel und laufe wieder in die andere
richtung und jetzt gehe ich hier im bund
nein das ist doch nicht wahr ich kann ja
gerade nicht schneiden weil es so
unfassbar zeitaufwendig ist sie die
ganze zeit weil halt alles direkt
nacheinander passiert aber und ich wurde
die kugel meine damen und herren ich
verstecke mich hier in so und springe
mein gott ich bin level-5 gerade ich
weiß nicht was hier gerade sache ist ich
bin ja einfach mal hoch ist so block
ball game was muss ich denn
was soll ich denn
wasser
was mache ich denn hier mist ich gehe
hier über ich gehe hier aber jetzt gucke
ich mich da
ich kann hier drücken dann geht es da
oben gegen ich kann auch noch mal
drücken und da sah
ich glaube ich weiß es geht kein scheiße
dass beschäftigte an diesem spiel ist
einfach dass man die ganze zeit wieder
von vorne anfangen muss und ich hoffe
die ganze dass ich dabei keine fehler
mache also hier zack so rüber hier jetzt
warte ich hier ab genau springen hier um
hier vorne kommt die kugel das heißt ich
stelle mich hierhin die kugel springt
über mich drüber ich wohl hier vorne das
rp hier vorne wieder hin hole die kugel
die kugel kommt wieder mit rüber ich
warte hier geil kugel holen die ist
wirklich direkt hinter mir gerade hier
hinstellen da bin ich natürlich wieder
tot freude das ist natürlich das macht
dann wie immer super viel spaß ich will
hier vorne wieder zackig hier vorne hin
hole die kugel die kugel kommen die
kugel ist wirklich direkt hinter mir
hier dunkeln die kugel kommt
ich gehe wieder zurückholen die kugel
von ja direkt umbringen google kommt
hier hingucken und direkt rüber springen
so zac jetzt bin ich hier vorn und ich
glaube jetzt wenn ich so drücke und hier
untergeht
oh mein gott ach du scheiße also ich
muss diese kugel abfeuern muss runter
gehen die kugel macht mir dann den
ganzen weg hier kaputt
wie soll ich denn ausweichen sagt hier
runter her unter der kugel die kugel
kommt wieder obenrum macht wieder hier
alles kaputt so wieder oben um die kugel
geht hier wieder lang also ich weiß
nicht was jetzt gerade das ziel hier ist
sie muss ich auch mal ganz kurz seiner
nase kratzen tut mir ganz im herzen weh
tue dann haben beide das ist doch nicht
war also ich bin hier drücke hier drauf
gehen runter die kugel macht jetzt quasi
hier vorne alles kaputt cool
auch beim mich töten hierhin kugel
abfeuern
ich bin direkt schon wieder tot hier in
kugel abfeuern runter gehen soll es
warten wir mal ab die kugel kommen macht
das jetzt kaputt ich muss hier drunter
her gehen genau jetzt warten wir mal
hier vorne aber google kontierung macht
mir das diesmal kaputt ich verstecke
mich jetzt mal hier runter hier geht die
kugel diesmal lang jetzt gehe ich mal
hier runter ich weiß nicht was da unten
für komische gegner jetzt sind drei
wochen später
will das mal vorangehen hier also ich
weiß nicht was ich jetzt gerade machen
soll weil dieses teil dreht sich ja
irgendwie nur im kreis und ich weiß
nicht was ich jetzt machen soll also da
unten sind gegen solche komischen
smileys reingekommen ich kann mich
einfach mal gucken
da passiert aber auch nix also kein
scheiß das problem deswegen die gerade
so ein bisschen dass sich diese kugler
die ganze zeit im kreis wenig weiß ich
noch mal da oben drauf kann
ich hasse dieses spiel also ich bin hier
oben drauf das heißt du jetzt einfach
mal zwei mal das heißt habe zwei kugeln
davon hier drin ich muss halt
und dabei
herr laufen das ist glaube ich unmöglich
ich könnte mir einfach nur eine kugel
genau die geht jetzt da oben gegen und
macht mir jetzt hier die sachen kaputt
das heißt darum
spiel es kann doch nicht so schwer sein
also ich warte hier ab da wie soll ich
denn da drunter her kommen ich kann
nicht über die kugel drüber springen
weil ich da oben in diesem komischen
bereich gehe ich kann natürlich ist
allerdings auch nicht drunter her gehen
weil die kugel so scheint sich vorher
die kugel abgrund hat die kugel kommt
hier wie soll ich denn da droht daher
ich vorher die kugel diesmal direkt hier
ab genau jetzt hier runter her das war
eine ganz gute taktik so als hat sie da
oben alles aktiviert geht jetzt hier
unten wieder her machten jetzt hier
wieder den weg kaputt und die kugel ist
auf der nächsten ebene angekommen das
heißt nicht spielt jetzt auf dieser
ebene sorgt google das machst du bisher
echt mega gut machst das jetzt hier
vorne kaputt jetzt hier vorne jetzt gehe
ich mal hierhin ich muss halt nur
irgendwie gleich auf diesem level hier
raus bzw
da unten an diesem smileys vorbei da
weiß ich allerdings auch nicht wie ich
da lang soll also da vorne ist jetzt auf
jeden fall weg soll ich das einfach mal
reingehen ich weiß es nicht ich will
doch ehrlich gesagt nicht riskieren
auch noch smileys drin cool jetzt gehe
ich hier rein tot
wie
in gottes namen es dieses spiel möglich
also hier ganz ans ende hin die kugel
abfeuern ich gehe runter gehe auf meine
zweite ebene oben ist das wieder
aktiviert das heißt ich warte jetzt hier
ab ist die gelbe kugel mir den nächsten
weg quasi eröffnet das ganze ist jetzt
der fall das heißt ich gehe jetzt nach
unten die smileys kommen so langsam rein
ich kann natürlich nicht irgendwie
beschleunigen der nächste weg ist frei
das heißt ich bin jetzt hier auf dieser
ebene das heisst jetzt warte ich wieder
auf
will
die kugel ist wieder fest gehangen ein
paar sekunden später
was soll das
kein scheiß
das liegt doch nicht an mir dass diese
kugel fest hängt mein letztes leben
freuen ich gehe wieder nach ganz hierhin
springe runter die kugel macht mir
wieder den ersten weg frei ich warte bis
die kugel auf der zweiten seite darum
kommt genauso macht mir das frei die
teile warte hier ab genau die kugel geht
nach vorne ihren weg noch da was kaputt
jetzt kann ich in die zweite ebene gehen
dieses level ist würde ich sagen 50
prozent können aber 50 prozent doch
einfach glück also natürlich irgendwie
die anderen level sind auch irgendwie
irgendwelche sachen war alles okay wir
haben einen weg offen ich glaube ich
warte man noch was die kugel mir noch
nie so eröffnet sie geht jetzt hier
forderung macht aus scheiße
ach du scheiße ok computer nein das ist
doch nicht wahr wie soll man dieses
level schaffen freunde es ist nicht
möglich ladet videos hoch ansage an luca
wieder schafft aber in meinen augen und
in meinem leben werde ich das nicht mehr
schaffen ende